what makes this such a good scene it's
it's like great design with such great
comedy at the same time it makes no
sense here's the other thing that i
okay can we go back let's go
back hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of stuntman react i'm
here with our friends chris cohen and
young lee and the boy boys this will be
a good episode these guys are
responsible for a lot of the really cool
action that you guys have seen uh both
in shanghai and the kingsman films some
of the stuff in solo heck even some of
the classic videos on the freddy w aka
rocket jump channel so we're going to
jump in some really cool action scenes
like some junkie action scenes because
i'm going to break down how they would
approach them differently let's jump so
stoked for this i've been
waiting all my life for this moment
let's take a look at the uh
agent smith versus neo fight
from the end of the first matrix what is
he doing
he's beginning to believe
what makes this such a good scene so
many good things here
i mean there's this
yeah that blew my mind it's the duality
of the shots the reverses like so many
as is neo smith neil smith it shows so
much about character here this is really
a story about character
i i love that it's so much of the cast
yeah doing the fighting it makes such a
big difference because then you can hold
on a shot
that wire moves so good i love that gag
i think it's one of the first hollywood
movies to really showcase hong kong wire
work shake off that dust man
yes the best
i love this cutting pattern if you so
wide tight wide tight that's and then
punch out wide again to see something
far away from camera coming close into
camera like and chris is like the expert
on this
is is when you want to get that anime
vibe that's it right there it sells the
impact in intensity
pushes are great man they are
not used enough every once while cutting
back out to the chair too just like you
said story points remind you what's
going on
if you're enjoying this episode but want
to see more we've got an extended
edition of it on the website
quarterdigital.com get the app in the
ios store and android all right so a
question for you guys about wonders or
long takes wonders has become a little
more popular ever since that fight scene
the church fights in kingsman and
they've been around before then but like
that one really brought the style like
to the forefront but a lot of them have
hidden cuts a lot of them have really
obviously hidden cuts what is your
guys's opinion on doing a wander but
having hidden cuts if i'm gonna do a
warner i lean on the hidden cuts but if
i'm going to do that it needs to be
hyper stylized like even when we're
working on kingsman too
and we were like okay we could put a
stitch here and it would just go over
someone's shoulder and then we'd be like
that's boring we don't want to just wipe
off someone's shoulder to do a hidden
cut like we have to find hidden cuts
that people won't be able to really
understand yeah
one of the reasons to do it is to switch
rigs see like that that's that's just
switched from like handheld to a track
shot
i can i can just tell this is your
camera chris
wish we could go back and make this way
better ah dude this is
great
it's good but yeah like i i feel the
same way i'm like camera rigs too like
oh my gosh so okay imagine a ronin rig
but no stabilizer
okay because it like predated
that technology and oh god if i could go
back and shoot this on a ronin now man
that was all matthew vaughn's thing with
the with the meat grinder like
he he always pitches like the craziest
stuff and it's it's like where do you
get these ideas it's so cool i love that
every time we do a movie with him first
thing he goes in he's like i want you to
go nuts
he like tells you to think outside the
box and if we have to scale it back we
can but like don't hold back just go go
crazy that's super cool yeah
i told my master i'd never fight because
have you seen this oh yeah have you ever
seen shaolin soccer right
have you heard of this anime called
dragon ball
it's like great design with such great
comedy at the same time it makes no
sense
i like how simple these shots are too
it's like that's probably just dragging
the dude you know like somebody just
holding up that's matrix right there oh
yeah he slides up the camera you're
right
more matrix yeah this is literally the
matrix right
this is 1999 by the way so those ragdoll
physics are actually pretty good it's
crazy
i don't know they did that i wanted to
just threw them at him honestly they
probably just threw that stuff out
they landed so well though yeah i mean
they could have easily just roddled him
out i know how sometimes they shoot
these movies yeah right just go for it
yeah like in the death dealer shot and
chung chi uh there's a
part where uh death dealer kicks
shang tree in the face and that's like a
full real kick it was wasn't supposed to
be a kick in the face
but it was fully real so there's so much
here story-wise so first of all this is
the very first scene you see this
character in action so immediately it
tells you the story that he's really
powerful so you get that point in that
shot right there but that's the second
point in that he's a good guy he doesn't
want to harm these people so it gives a
really strong character
moment and then you have the cyber
stylized matrix show it sets the tone of
what kind of movie you're going to watch
so if you guys have some cool crazy
live-action anime adaptations that like
really feel like they are capturing the
spirit of anime please leave a comment
down below so we can take a look at them
for a future episode of either stuntman
react or visual effects artist react
thank you for the comments we appreciate
it
all right so monster there's an
adaptation of monster hunter the the
video game it's it's the sad thing about
like we all love video games and it's
what happens when they don't really
respect the source material monster is
about a game where you go out and
basically you're hunting monsters and oh
really yeah you know what i mean
the world i think is rich enough that
you could have had a insanely rich story
this should not have been this
i'll say that
there's a lot of coverage in this
they're just cutting cutting cutting
cutting cutting but
you could tell it's like they didn't
plan it yeah is what you're noticing is
that when they're cutting to these shots
there's not a new phrase of information
being added to the story it's like
they're running on the sand and they're
running on the sand that's a lot of
running running in the sand running in
the sand
it's like they're running on the sand
and they're getting closer to this and
then they have this line of dialogue
like it's not story beats that are
happening it's just the same beat yeah
whatever they could have told this story
from a single shot
here's the other thing that i
okay can we go back to us let's go back
can
okay so wait how many cuts let's count
it one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
twelve thirteen
fourteen so like here's the thing what's
the story happening here right he's down
on the ground he needs to get up
and he needs to retract his bow and
release aim and release
really if you tell that story like how
many shots do we need to tell the story
uh
13 exactly 13.
but it does strike me as a lot of
different people giving opinions and
input on like i want to be exciting i
need it to be exciting and then like the
other thing they're being like well
i guess the only way i can even address
a note is to change it another way to
change is just chop more stuff into it
yeah and make it exciting i love holding
shots
and just amps up the suspense and it
just makes you feel like you're part of
it you know you're there with the
character
you just get fully immersed in that
there was so much in this the cutting
pattern super tight and then super wide
super tight and then the problem when
you do so many cuts and you go super
tight super wide in succession is you
begin to you lose the audience because
the whole point of visual storytelling
is to get the audience to focus on
something and the moment we keep cutting
away we lose all the focus i feel like
the only shot in here that actually
achieves what you guys are talking about
is a shot where you see the poison drip
from the arrow and then iraq focuses
down to him aiming mm-hmm like that this
one shot here tells the story and hits
the stream right yeah it really does hey
if you're not subscribed to this channel
you're basically just asking the youtube
robot to decide what you want to watch
and just have it give it to you and that
can be cool but with this series maybe
you want to decide to watch it so
consider subscribing if you're not
already i've been wanting to play this
on seven reaction it's been a while uh
they live as like a good classic 80s
camp film
uh with a pro wrestler as the main
character so this these glasses he has
let's lets him see
like the others the monsters that are
living within society he's trying to get
this guy to put on these glasses hey
stay away from me i'm telling you you
dumped out of it
i missed this like the spirit of this
film making from the 80s
yeah pissed off like in your face
i love the mist
dude you've been done by now serious
why'd you put all the glasses man
or something
yo back in that day yeah that's freaking
concrete
they're not doing a rubber mat right
there
oh my gosh
i have never seen that before
no he gave him like three of those
why have we not seen that move ever it's
going to be in our next movie okay
you know what this reminds me of a
family guy fight
oh right
this is probably what he's inspired him
honestly
dude wrestling moves are so hype in real
life they really are
what do you guys think about that fight
scene that was enjoyable yo i loved it
it's funny how like you know fight
scenes like this like they carry so much
emotion and they get you like so amped
up yeah but like there's clear misses
like this thing's just like yeah it's a
movie but like it almost like engages
you even more you know with writing like
when we look at scripts and we think of
the action
what helps us the most is not
necessarily the choreography it's really
the pacing and the tone and feeling of
the action scene so like if this is
written out like talking about how
brutal and raw they're going to be
and long-winded
and reveals too i think yeah the reveals
those story points you're right like
reveal the board reveal the bottle
yup
we talk about star wars go for it let's
do it i want it i want it when we do
projects we want to look at what the
fans like and that's important i was so
so psyched for the new star wars films
coming out at that time because
i loved star wars the old republic and
their cinematics i think the first one
that came out blew my freaking mind oh
they were next level everyone was
talking about me
like this is
look like i would have no problem they
literally just ripped ripped and put it
in the movie i i would just be
yeah and the fans would go nuts yeah
fans are going to that moment we got
nothing even close
to this in the sequels there's nothing
even close to this in the scene kind of
like the technology that we have these
days and we couldn't get a lightsaber
fight that just blew people's minds
hurts hurts my heart yeah that's
actually i mean that's one of the things
about the lightsabers like you see it
here it's like they're jedi so they can
they know everything going on around
them so the lightsaber fight should be
these hyper precise as if robots were
like perfectly executing everything oh
yeah right and then so you get here when
you have animation because you can have
everything be like centimeters away from
misses everything's position perfect you
know i feel like george lucas was right
in the prequels when it came to the
speed of the sabers for some reason in
the sequels
they made them very heavy and slow and
weighted and i'm like the last time that
we had our minds blown in the theaters
was darth maul yeah that's one of the
most hyped swords ever
funny watching this now it looks like a
fan film
it does but this was the right speed
they had it so right i love the the
break and like the pause after this
it just shows you the contrast between
right because it goes into meditation
yeah yeah
just pacing the whole time
it builds that anticipation
and sometimes it's good to not give what
the audience wants to hold it for a
moment i argue actually that the
anticipation is better than the payoff
yeah the audience holds their breath the
most and their hearts are being the
fastest before the payoff happens
the hyper fast bit at the end when
qui-gon dies and obi-wan just goes all
out yeah oh yeah the behind the back
block which you've never seen before
yeah
the rhythm is so
i'm hoping just one day that we get a
star wars that goes in like this on the
action just one day george lucas has
made too cool of a weapon and like just
lure behind these people that can move
with this weapon for us to not have our
minds blown in theaters that was the
guys star wars
do you like stunts do you want to learn
more about them well guess what on our
website quarterdigital.com we dive even
deeper into some of the inside baseball
of how stunts work and how to do it
safely sign up now get a two-week trial
and get everything that we put out
including a fifteen percent off all of
our merchandise access to all of our
exclusive shows like crew cuts son of a
dungeon functional filmmaking it's great
and the future is looking bright i
highly recommend getting a subscription
you can also get an ios and android app
on the app store near you well this is
one of the most enjoyable sessions of uh
something react we've ever filmed uh
thanks for joining us guys thank you for
this emotional experience
dude oh man i'm still feeling it yeah if
you guys want to follow any of their
work uh chris has a youtube channel
riven x3 i want a link in the
description below same thing instagram
ribbon x3i if you want to check out uh
young's stuff or follow him at all uh he
has an instagram young and the dangerous
i'll link in the description below this
was a good time let's go play some smash
brothers yes